okay so gen z are pumping doge instead
of bitcoin but
why is this i think i may have an answer
bitcoin and doge are very different
especially from a technical fundamental
standpoint
now bitcoin isn't about life-changing
gains anymore
right now you'd have to put in a lot of
money to be able to actually make
life-changing gains instead bitcoin has
adopted a narrative that is more about
protecting your wealth from inflation
and from the government but the issue
here
is that financial education still hasn't
changed schools still aren't teaching
financial literacy so the younger
generation don't understand these key
issues so gen z aren't understanding the
fundamental value of bitcoin but what
they do understand
is the potential to get rich quick off
of coins like doge